the energy regulator has warned that the  UK is facing a significant risk of gas  shortages this winter the information  revealed in a letter sent from off gem  last week first revealed by the times it  spoke with the possibility of what they  call a gas supply emergency measures  during due to the impacts of the Russian  war in Ukraine which of course has  starved Europe from its main supply of  natural gas and what that could mean is  that some customers could be asked to  stop using gas for a temporary period  the largest industrial consumers first  to try and keep the supply as stable for  house holds as long as possible at Sky  News are of course talking to off-term  expecting a statement to try and clarify  the official position but that the  energy regulator off gem has warned the  UK facing a significant risk of gas  shortages this winter we will bring you  more on that story when we get